i want to dig into some spoilers with
some of our chat here
all right jaz i'll go to you first on
this
in our last interview you told me that
it was shocking when
roz became a cheerleader what was your
initial reaction to finding out she was
a full-blown witch
um well i celebrated i told everybody
who would listen to me about it
i was very happy and i still am very
happy about it
um it's legitimately a dream come true
because i'm
i'm just a huge harry potter fan which
fan in general and
uh is one of the reasons why i wanted to
be on this show was the witchy element
of it
and uh we've just created such a cool
world so to get to take this character
that i spent so much time in and to let
her walk through the doors of the
academy and walk into that
was like such a special kind of treat
for me i loved
every second of it when you found that
out did that change the way
you looked at roz at all like is roz
still razzed to the core
or have you seen everything sabrina did
throughout the entire show did that
kind of open the door to a new side of
her for you
i would say that it opened i think roz
has always been
known that she was more powerful than
she was letting herself be
i think roz is like i'm gonna be the
student council president and i'm gonna
you know be a cheerleader and i'm gonna
be like a stand-up citizen
uh more than she was like how powerful
am i
um so i don't i don't know that she was
so
surprised by it it kind of made sense
um i think i think it plays like that
too
yeah for both of you now relationships
have always been a very big part of
sabrina but
part four in particular leans into how
having a relationship or not having one
can play a big part in
shaping someone's uh identity and
self-worth
so were there any specific qualities of
raz and theo that felt like an anchor of
sorts while you were exploring how those
relationships
changed them but also didn't define them
i think
uh theo's boldness and loyalty
really was an interesting anchor um
that's such an interesting question to
think about
but um yeah i think i think loyalty is
definitely an undertone of theo's whole
existence
that on sabrina ceo's always sort of
been
loyal to jazz or loyal to raz
[Music]
loyal to sabrina and now now loyal to
robin
but i think in part four theo's really
learning how to be
loyal to himself which is really cool so
that's been an interesting
underlying factor um and and theo's
willingness to take risks and
theo's willingness to take risks for
other people i think definitely shows up
in in their relationships as well which
is really cool roz
knows everything so you can't lie to roz
and roz can't lie to roz either um
so i really liked that in in
the show how that played into the
relationships how there were
a few uncomfortable conversations that
had to be had because raz is
just honest in her nature and in her
powers um
i think that made for some really
beautiful tender moments
whether we wanted them or not as the
characters
um yeah i think that that that the
honesty and the like
like inability to not know the truth was
an anchor
for roz and love this part so his
qualities are a big reason why i love
the character so much and i love the
show
seriously thank you guys so much for
just making
covering this such an incredible treat
and pleasure
thank you it's been a pleasure and
seriously thank you so much